today we are competing for office Arnold
Schwarzenegger
[Music]
[Laughter]
welcome back to the impersonator
Olympics we've done them in the past
they're basically the best things ever
and today is no exception because today
we are competing for office Arnold
Schwarzenegger Arnold Schwarzenegger is
just a hero in my heart he was in my
childhood he was in all of our
childhoods he brought us up so the
people we are today so we are here to
honor his name and compete with each
other to find out who is the office
Arnold Schwarzenegger I'm terminated
from Terminator 1 and none of these men
know it's coming form if it bleeds we
can kill it John matrix commando you
know I carry this tree and I don't have
any business with the government guys we
are here for our first challenge it is
the son of a [ __ ] challenger [ __ ] my
personal favorite this is a two-person
elimination Rob we're gonna pick names
out of a hat match our Arnold's up and
see who can clasp flex the louder the
better
all right two men at all together will
have one shot at this I'm going to need
absolute silence
and I hear those steps I need absolute
quiet Phil you son of a [ __ ] a measly
eighty two point two on a decibel me
[Music]
take off me you watch the secret to
everybody I need absolute quiet on set
for an accurate scientific measurement
[Music]
be eliminated I say because your voices
send the record hovering around 77
decibels they did worse than Wren and
Jordan it's hard to actually judge that
estimating here all I know is that you
didn't break 82 we'll call it a TA I'm
dominating who's belted here's the issue
is they've known each other their whole
lives you're our only chance at this
point is for them to mess up I know just
like with Bruce Lee it's hip twist to
give you all the power it's quiet on set
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we stand a chance we have an
impartial judge coming in Christian the
one down here all right so we're
starting with Jordan and ran son of a
[ __ ] oh they slid into position saw the
Flex those random every [ __ ] looked
really good really good it sound like
two babies high-fiving alright this is
salmon is really just the examinee curve
lifelong friends visually would need to
shoot another tank other than the
decibel I think that's the elimination
clip right there
alright challenge number two the mr.
freeze challenge now mr. freeze his
whole motivations that his wife was
dying of an incurable illness so he
froze her until he could find a cure
we're gonna give it each mr. freeze
contestant their very own frozen wife
and they will have to keep her frozen as
long as they can
now mr. freeze is also known for his
excessive use of ice related puns mercy
I'm afraid that the conditioners left me
cold to your pleas of mercy
I'll be putting them each on the spot
asking for an ice related pun and if
they don't give me one little Missy gets
the heat gun Martha
Stacy Stacy Sarah moment no body needs
as nails Wow oh I thought of that first
my wife likes blue shirts it's holding
pretty fast like speed rounds poke out I
see a toe mr. breeze you should turn
yourself in the chances of that are
absolute zero do kiss your mother with
that mouth I do
ice do where's your friend the penguin
it's time for a vacation we're turning
up to max we're gonna test their
knowledge on ice trivia which Stan in
2014 had the most hail damage claims
Texas yeah our most types of ice more or
less dense than water laughs yeah the
polar icecap layers of Mars have been
shown to contain seasonal layers Oh what
type of nitrogen carbon dioxide I'm
hanging in my way tell me what type of
ice is often found in space how many
known solid crystalline phases of water
are there which Rover photographed the
Martian polar ice caps first opportunity
what was the oldest known major Ice Age
called
I'd say the cryogenian
you melt the plastic I think maybe
losing or mr. Freeze's have kept their
wives alive as long as they can let's
see which wife is the least frozen and
most likely to die nicely frozen why you
are very least ice most ice medium ice
second I'm sorry man keep her alive
well we all know who our mr. freeze
isn't we are going to be paying homage
to one of our favorite Arnold scenes the
chase scene from Terminator 2 the scene
has everything you want it got Arnold in
a leather jacket riding a motorcycle
lasted away with this shotgun at the
evil t1000
so our Arnold's will have to ride down
the street on it a bike shoot a standing
target reload using the famous
one-handed flip technique then face off
against a real t1000 yes we brought him
back from the future they'll have to do
all this while looking as badass as
possible strategy is channel the inner
Arnold this is all about the momentum
living in the moment most people they
don't know how to live in the moment
watch me get into it
first I need to get to spin the reel oh
that's easy
don't shoot from far away I'm already
winning based off of coolness points
I've never shot with my left hand before
but once everyone's done their run our
judges panel of lesser Arnold's will
tally up the style points and crown the
office Arnold Schwarzenegger we shot
this little scene we've edited together
the most badass of the shots that we got
we need to see who the real terminator
is
[Music]
where is that quit what is it where's
the revolver was in it was in the it was
in the other body no no thank you
yeah feels like something was cut or
something you know man something's
missing
next up we have Terminator 1
I mean together like the successful
victory pose at the end laughing the
whole time missing all the show yeah
well I mean comedic value what's the
point in shooting at a t-1000 it just
the regenerate dude that's terminator
having a good time
next up we have John matrix
[Music]
that looks like it's straight out of the
movie wes is left-handed my left hand
right now I'm not left-handed I did with
my left hand I'm left-handed but I can
only do writing on my left hand
everything else is right hand yeah
terminator can be right with both hands
at the same time which is eyes closed
but I don't have to think about it's
definitely clay I think it's pretty
clear that Clint has this one in the bag
Clint is finally won his that was your
first obvious Olympics I finally time to
put the log down and claim what is
rightfully mine
thank you are the offices Arnold
Schwarzenegger yes but there's one
person I'd like to thank from the bottom
of my soul and that is my man my main
son Clifford the B Laurette thank you so
much for inspiring me to be Who I am
[Applause]
thank you for watching it was truly an
honor to win today if you like these
videos then there are more just like
this one where you can see everyone
competing for different celebrity roles
comment below if you have any ideas of
your own we can compete for those as
well and if you like us moving around
maybe having some fun you know then
maybe head over to the podcast because
we we have a blast doing that as well
and if you're not subscribed then you
know subscribe and don't forget we have
know much over in the store there's a
new motion capture hoodie it captures my
muscles and go to chordal digital that
store we have something for everyone put
the cookie down and go there now